ich möchte heute über die
bundesverfassungsgerichts entscheidungen
sprechen meines erachtens also die zu
einem breite einrichtungs bezogenen im
pflicht ist das eine bankrotterklärung
gewesen und ja also zunächst einmal
abgesehen davon dass die entscheidung
völlig an unserer lebensrealität
vorbeigeht denn wir alle wissen dass
geimpfte und gebürstete sich anstecken
und auch das virus natürlich weiter
geben aber was mich besonders bewegt und
mir große sorgen bereitet ist der
paradigmenwechsel des
bundesverfassungsgerichts wenn ich
paradigmenwechsel sage dann meine ich
dass das gericht bisher die
vorherrschende denkweise geteilt hat
dass der staat in der freiheits
einschränkungen vornimmt diese sehr gut
begründen muss davon ist es jetzt aber
komplett abgekehrt was heißt das jetzt
für uns was heißt das für jeden
einzelnen das bedeutet konkret dass der
staat immer dann wenn er vorgibt
menschenleben retten zu wollen in
krisensituationen eben insbesondere
eigentlich alle maßnahmen ergreifen darf
insbesondere auch solche die relativ
offensichtlich untauglich sind oder
nahezu untauglich sind zum beispiel eine
impfpflicht mit einer impfung die nicht
vor ansteckung schützt das heißt das
gericht hat im prinzip im zweifel für
den staat entschieden und sagt immer nur
dann wenn klar widerlegt ist dass eine
annahme nicht zutreffend ist gibt es
sozusagen eine rote linie jetzt ist es
so dass der staat grundsätzlich auch
eine vergangenheit schon einen gerne
tendenz dazu hat in krisensituationen
zum beispiel bekämpfung raf-terrorismus
unverhältnismäßig in die grundrechte
einzugreifen das ist ein impuls der
fläche menschlich nachvollziehbar ist
aber gerade dann brauchen wir eben ein
gericht was sagt stopp so geht das nicht
weiter wir haben aber hier gerade das
gegenteil davon erlebt haben ein gericht
erlebt was ein quasi ein blankoscheck
ausgefüllt hat und gesagt hat hierfür
grundrechts einschränkungen zum schutz
von leben und so weiter
krisensituationen ist das jetzt gibt's
keine roten linien ich glaube dass diese
entscheidung den rechtsstaat in einen
unerträglichen zustand versetzt hat die
menschen ohnmächtig zurückgelassen hat
und dadurch auch potenziell den sozialen
frieden bedroht der herbst steht an es
werden jetzt schon wieder corona
maßnahmen ins feld geführt corona pause
ist zum narrativ gewann was sich
irgendwie auch schon herr buschmann
angeeignet hat klimaschutz ist ein
weiteres großes thema und ich frage mich
wer schützt uns jetzt eigentlich noch
vor dem übergriffigen staat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ist es nämlich
nicht die frage sollen wir direkt meine
herrn stegner weiter geben ob danach auf
unser rechtssystem vertrauen kann und
auch keine zunächst medizin habe ich
sehr viel sympathie dafür zu sagen die
bürgerrechte gehör nicht im staats und
sie kann den bürgern und man darf sie
nur einschränken wenn das begründet ich
bin aber auch da bei meinem nächsten
pessimistisch wie sie das gleiche
bundesverfassungsgericht hat entschieden
wenn ein flugzeug gekapert wird und
fliegt aus der stadt zu darf der staat
das nicht abschießen heißt aber auch
dass dafür nicht nur jedes da darf es
nicht tun aber man darf eine kommune
einzigen nicht vergessen das haben wir
aber schon vergessen dass in der korona
pandemie
wahnsinnig viele menschen einsam und
alleine gestorben sind ja oft haben es
gerade in einer gerade in altenheim urin
kann einlenken gelten müsste man noch
einen eigenen lager in reitstunden oder
werkstätten und anderswo woanders sich
um bürger kümmern müssen mit einer folge
über die wir bei weitem nicht
abgearbeitet haben da hat es dann wir
nicht mehr beerdigungen gegeben außer
den familien selbst
den nachbarn den freunden und denen die
als pflegekräfte teilweise familie sagt
geschwinde eine gruselige sache
sozusagen die sie nicht wiederholen darf
und wir haben auch beim das gefällt oder
nicht in dieser pandemie gelernt dass
das sehr viel mehr menschen gestorben
sind als hätten sterben müssen wenn wir
nach dem der impfstoff entwickelt worden
ist eine höhere impfquote gehabt hätten
denn diese info schützt zwar nicht vor
anstellt jahre aber dass dann mehr zu
ende führen bitte sie schützt schon
davor
lebensbedrohlich zu erkranken dass ich
davor schützt ja diejenigen die davon
auch sowie tot
gerade so zu sagen ich beamten nur 100
toten dass der staat sich kümmern das
ist eine die gesundheit zu erhalten
recht auf leben zu sichern das verstehe
ich schon es darf nicht so weit gehen
dass bürgerliche freiheiten
eingeschränkt werden über das maß hinaus
was in arbeiten das ist doch genau wenn
ich das sagen darf oder bzw also als
frage an frau hart weil ich es
tatsächlich nicht weiß aber ich habe
diesen satz in erinnerung ich habe mir
das urteil auch an geguckt wo sich das
bundesverfassungsgericht in einem der
zentralen absätze ich eigentlich darauf
büro im beruf dass die
fachgesellschaften in diesem saal waren
gemeint das paul-ehrlich-institut usw
angeraten hätten und so weiter weil die
fachgesellschaften das jetzt so sagen
darum kann das bundesverfassungsgericht
sagen ich schränke die grundrichtung
genau jetzt mache ich mal ein beispiel
ja also sein beispiel ja also demnächst
habe ich ein paar demografen diese
demografen stellen fest wir haben zu
wenig kinder ja wir brauchen wieder drei
kinder pro frau sodann kam diese
fachgesellschaft demographie geht zum
bundesverfassungsgericht und sagt das
recht mein bauch gehört mir wofür wir
mal gestritten haben in den 19 und 70er
jahre dieses recht ist jetzt mal so zu
sagen weil die fachgesellschaft das
anders sehen werden diese rechte
abgeräumt ist das ist ein sehr
technokratisch das verständnis was ich
hier gezeigt hat wobei man hat es
runtergebrochen auf die regierung darf
so zu sagen hat natürlich einen gewissen
einschätzungsspielraum auch völlig
zurecht allerdings wurde der hier
eindeutig überstrapaziert denn was auch
die fachgesellschaften nicht gesagt
haben hier ging es ja in der
entscheidung ging es ja vor allem um
fremdschutz ich möchte auch noch mal auf
ihren stegner eingehen weil sie das
beispiel mit dem luftsicherheitsgesetz
angesprochen haben selbst wenn wir sagen
okay von mir aus diesen ganz weiden
einschätzungsspielraum und die
fachgesellschaften haben zumindest
gesagt na ja irgendwie im wirkung 41
kommend was prozent was erschreckend ist
wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt das ist
nur um fremdschutz ging aber die
ureigenen verfassungsrechtlichen fragen
nämlich darf ich menschenleben gegen
menschenleben abwägen wie damals in der
luftsicherheitsgesetz entscheidung nehme
ich jetzt ist ja ganz klar dass durch
die impfung stadt darüber können wir zu
schreiben in welchem ausmaß aber die
führt eben in einigen fällen dazu dass
menschen sehr schwer erkranken gesunde
menschen sehr schwer erkranken oder
sterben das heißt ich opfere faktisch
einen teil der aber ich hoffe faktisch
menschen nehmen um andere zu retten
warum hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
lehnt lediglich einsatz dazu gesagt im
sinne von na ja aber es ist so so selten
und man rettet so sehr viele ohne auf
diese ureigene frage die die
menschenwürde berührt einzugehen und das
ist ein absolutes total versagen selbst
einmal alles andere sagen würde okay
geht noch wenn ich dann fertig 2
anmerkung dazu erstens sind wir wieder
in unserem punkt dass es dinge gibt die
so nicht vermitteln können sie werden
der mehrzahl und das ist sind zwei
drittel die sich haben impfen lassen nie
vermitteln können dass es ein ausdruck
von freiheit sei dass ungeimpfte
jederzeit rumlaufen können andere
anstecken und zwar leichter als die
geimpften und sich auch selbst gefahr
aber wieso denn nicht
in meinen augen wo die freiheit das ist
auch eine freiheit von von
bin gesinnungs liberale aber da teile
ich die haltung der
freiheit ob sich
viele leute daran gestorben das können
sie nicht vergessen ja das erste mal
geschlagen dass die leute trotz
versprechen dann ist aber geschichte der
wurden angelegt dass ganz viele menschen
gestorben sind die länger hätten leben
können haben wir im moment sind sie in
die pflicht die leute und war selbst
gegeben hätte sicher dass leute sehen
das ist ein anderes als der eine hat
sich dem weg zu holen ist deutlich
geringer als er eingriffe nicht dass ich
mein leben beendet weil entweder mich
jemand anstecke ja was sie da habe ich
auf den intensivstationen
die situation habe man
dagegen
rundum dass wir uns beide weiter das
inhaltlich was ja richtig
deutlich mehr als nicht geben so sehen
aber wir müssen noch einmal ins
verhältnis das ganze setzen ja klar ist
jeder gestört sein also jeder der stirbt
ist einer zu viel einsatz den sie in
einer freiheitlichen demokratie einfach
so und ich sagen würde ohne zu sterben
musst ja straßenverkehr dem ja auch
nicht haben oder also deswegen haben wir
das nicht in ordnung jetzt fangen wir an
über hilfen generell
sollte was ich sagen wollte mich wundert
ihre einlassung dieses urteil sie könnte
sie das ist mir völlig konsequent dass
die entscheidende weichenstellung war
ein anderes urteil des
verfassungsrechtlich als sie die
verfassungsklage der tp abgeschmettert
haben da steht alles drin und das ist
von aktionismus gemeindebundes notbremse
da steht da drin alle einzelmaßnahmen
hoch bedenklich da eigentlich geht das
gar nicht aber in gänze hat der staat
doch diesen henry lionel und wollte ihn
und ich bin einen größeren letzten thema
keine einigung halten soll das gleiche
manöver 18 freie debattenkultur